-Making his TV debut, performing
"Chosen" with Ty Dolla $ign
from the deluxe edition
of his album "No Love Lost,"
here is Blxst!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Ayy ♪
♪ When it come to you ♪
♪ Pistol I
bust, issue with trust ♪
♪ Won't let no one get
a piece of your love ♪
♪ Yeah, base it on loyalty,
base it on us ♪
♪ I ain't the picture-perfect
type, but I'm makin' it up ♪
♪ You say you want a bag
flipper, you can't get enough ♪
♪ I'm rich alone, but when I'm
with you, I'm richer as what? ♪
♪ Forbidden fruit on apple
juice, can I sip on the cup? ♪
♪ Mix it with some 1940 ♪
♪ Girl, you chosen ♪
♪ Get up when you bust
wide open ♪
♪ It's a ocean,
I'm just imposin' ♪
♪ That you give it to me
and just me only ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Girl, you chosen ♪
♪ Get up when you bust
wide open ♪
♪ It's a ocean,
I'm just imposin' ♪
♪ That you give it to me
and just me only ♪
-♪ Dolla $ign ♪
♪ Girl, you're chosen ♪
♪ Sign this NDA, no,
you can't bring no phones in ♪
♪ We walk in, and they're like,
"What's all that commotion?" ♪
♪ No, they can't step a foot in
here if we don't know them ♪
♪ I treat you special, girl,
I hit you with the roses ♪
♪ Can't stand your boyfriend,
he too controllin' ♪
♪ Get along better with me ♪
♪ Goin' up when you bust
wide open ♪
-♪ Girl, you chosen ♪
♪ Get up when you bust
wide open ♪
♪ It's a ocean,
I'm just imposin' ♪
♪ That you give it to me
and just me only ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Girl, you chosen ♪
♪ Get up when you bust
wide open ♪
♪ It's a ocean,
I'm just imposin' ♪
♪ That you give it to me
and just me only ♪
♪♪
♪ Girl, you chosen ♪
♪ Get up when you bust
wide open ♪
♪ It's a ocean,
I'm just imposin' ♪
♪ That you give it to me
and just me only ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Girl, you chosen ♪
♪ Get up when you bust
wide open ♪
♪ It's a ocean,
I'm just imposin' ♪
♪ That you give it to me
and just me only ♪
♪♪